[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i have the honor of being joined
by angela siroffian aka jessica and leah
mchugh aka anna in the new thriller a
house on the bayou how are you ladies
doing today
good how are you
good good so i love this film i'm so
excited to talk to both of you about it
uh leah my first question is actually
for you you already have this in this
bright young queer you have this like
long track record of doing horror and
thriller films are you getting like sick
of the genre yet or you still find that
same love for it like taking a role like
this
i think even though they're all a lot of
the things that i've done our horror
movies i find such like a drastic
difference between all of them
and i don't really choose movies based
on the genre it's it's a lot about you
know the character and the storyline
um i don't think i've gotten tired of
horror yet i think maybe i mean it's a
lot of work to like cry all day so maybe
i've gotten a little sick of that
sure sure
no but you kill it at doing that so that
that's awesome you have this range doing
all these different times of films now
angela talk to me about being the lead
here do you feel there's an added
pressure to whenever you're a lead or do
you approach it like you do any other
kind of role you get
um well definitely there is a
responsibility in telling the entire
story and if you're on every single page
there's a journey so if i'm on page one
and speech 10 it can't be the same thing
um so when i'm working on this
i think every project is different
and i felt really really lucky because i
got to work with such great actors like
leah and jacob and paul and
you know we had such a great group of
people so
um
every every opportunity has its own
demands and for example i did another
movie called king night and
in kid night it was it was a lot of fun
but it was it was so light-hearted and
it was so funny and and satirical so man
yeah no for sure and i love too though
also that you mentioned that you know
you guys all got along in this cast and
being with leah here and you guys here
together so that shifting that that same
topic leah you previously posted on
instagram that angel is your favorite
person in the world how valuable is that
as having that kind of relationship with
the scene partner
i love her so much i look up to her like
like crazy i loved her so much when we
were filming and you know we talked a
lot after every time i'm in you know
where she lives i go see her we have
lunch and have a fun day um i mean you
just really get to know someone when you
work with them for like
all day every day for weeks and you know
even offset we were with each other
i don't like it's really special to have
that kind of a relationship with someone
you know because sometimes when i'm with
someone for a long time it's like hard
to put up with them you know like when
i'm you know like you need a break from
people sometimes but i never like ever
felt that way on set i mean which is
which is rare to be with someone so much
and just want to get to be with them
more i hated being by myself in my hotel
room i hated it when they were busy and
they and they couldn't come down and
hang out i'm like oh i have nothing to
do
but yeah she's my she is my favorite
person oh my god that's amazing and so
you would say you would you never felt
you need a break from angela which is
awesome angela can you say the same
about leah did you ever feel like i need
a break from this this girl right now
you know what it's really interesting i
had so the only reason she and i
couldn't be together is because
i had to prepare for the next day of
the scene so basically if i didn't have
to prepare i'd be hanging out with her
for coconut because it was a bunny
um
and jacob jacob was like the fourth
person that you know we were for some i
guess and we had such great adventures
and
i still to this day think about you know
all those times after work we would get
together and look at the scenes and play
sometimes we would switch parts
oh my gosh
we
did a really serious scene one time we
were all just like making comedy of it
and laughing we're laughing
apparently we're trying to memorize the
lines for the next day and
so it was just it was a lot of fun
that that's amazing and i love like i
feel this great just vibe between you
two here right now which is awesome um
but i wonder too angela does you guys
playing this mother-daughter
relationship like
is there something with acting in that
type of intimate role
that translates going on in life between
you two do you feel kind of like a
mother figure now to leah or is it is it
can you snap out of that kind of you
know you know it's interesting because i
don't think that i think that our
relationship is unique my relationship
with you is very different than your
typical kind of cliche idea of what a
mother and daughter must be for me it
was about this friendship this genuine
connection with her that i had i felt a
natural sense of protection i saw this
innocence in her that this sweetness
this person that's now becoming a
beautiful woman um and i i just i was
thinking that i want to honor that
relationship because she and i are
playing these parts you know whatever is
on the page we bring that life to it so
the relationship is
one of of true respect and friendship i
thought with this mother dynamic yeah
and i mean it comes off in the film
really well and i i love that dynamic in
the film and enjoy that and that it
focuses on character and you guys bring
that and leah i'm wondering too
having this young career now and you're
watching someone like angela work who's
been around for a bit are you kind of
taking notes in your head do you kind of
observe everything on the set and take
everything in are you is there something
like learning from working with angela
wait before you answer that leah we've
been working as an actress since like
four right five
yeah since i was seven
no no no
no i know i know that i'm just saying
like compared to you got this huge huge
resume so like is there something there
that's like you know what i
yeah do you mean
like you're learning
i feel like
there's nothing that beats experience so
i mean no class like enough there's
nothing you can like prepare yourself
for than just going to set and working i
mean
i sort of feel that way with roles
sometime too sometimes you just gotta
like get down in it and just really
you know be be in the moment and sort of
put the pressure on yourself to give
your best performance but
like observing actors is so valuable on
any set
and watching the way that angela worked
and how good she was
like i i wanted her to be like impressed
with me she i really wanted her
to like you know
i guess
like me like she had this really she set
this high standard on set every day and
she was she was so nice to everyone too
you know sometimes actors are a little
bit kind of
you know involved in themselves a little
bit or just very like you know quieter
in the corner but she would spend time
to get throughout to know everyone was
so nice everyone loved her and she still
gave this incredible performance
yeah that's that's amazing and angela
that's what you feel so good hearing
that and like that's again i i think
there is that thing too or when i'm
watching filming this it relates to
because how good the film is and seeing
that everyone got along and brought such
a cool product out and speaking of
different like great projects you guys
have both done angela i feel like you've
worked on so many great projects do you
find yourself now having a certain
standard for what roles you take like is
there is there something like you try to
avoid when you see kind of parts that
are offered to you
it's not about avoiding parts it's
really about connecting to the story so
a lot of the time by reading even first
even the first two pages i'll know but
i'll obviously i'll give it a chance and
go all the way to like 30 40 even i'll
always read the full script but it's
about what can i give to this role that
leads me to want to take on
meaning
i i'm not judging it based on budget i'm
not judging it necessarily based on
people involved i'm really judging it
based on what
they they want to tell and usually
you could sense that pretty early on so
that's that's the drive plus um
i i like to
i like to believe that the roles that
come for a reason
so
there's a chemistry there too
yeah i know it makes total sense that's
an amazing answer and
it's interesting too
leah i have to bring up it's like this
exciting time for you now being in this
huge movie the eternals and being in a
blockbuster like that with that extra
attention that comes to you
do you what does it feel like having now
like is it's kind of scary knowing that
now whatever project you do there's
going to be people who are just going to
go watch it because you're in it or does
that feel kind of exciting
i'm really excited that i'm able to have
more opportunities to be able to be in
more films now that i'm a little bit
more out there than i was before which
is a nice and it sort of is a little bit
of weight off my shoulders but like also
at the same time it i mean even doing
eternals i was nervous because i know
that the fans have a certain expectation
of characters in the mcu so
i i feel like yeah in the future i it's
definitely important
what projects i choose and you know how
how well i perform
yeah i mean and it's awesome because you
get this big role and spray and you
absolutely crushed it as one of my
favorite parts of the film um and angela
in that same realm like you know what
really got me just so in love with your
acting was your role of clementine on
westworld and that being such a big
highlighted role and project
is it all blessings when that happens is
there some kind of negative to it is
there a side we're not seeing because
from like my view it's like wow i wish i
was that and had that like is there some
downside
there you know i felt very fortunate so
working with people that i love i've now
worked with them for seven years and
from the show runners to the crew to the
actors everybody involved there is this
care and love for what we're making and
so
to be able to enliven
clementine i i've fallen
very much in love with her and her
journey and it's been unpredictable
unpredictable from season to season
where it's been developed
so
it's been a very i have to say i'm
grateful for the experience
for
having a chance to bring her to life
and i don't know what's around the
corner there's a passing word
she and i spoke a while ago and she said
you never know what's around the point
so
yeah that makes me excited that's
awesome um and running off of this like
exciting stuff you're both doing leah i
think it's cool you just post on
instagram that there's a happy meal toy
of you now is right
that's surreal and and you're saying
your mom got 20 of them which is crazy
awesome
it was so ridiculous
yeah like do you collect though or like
do you go now and get the funko pop of
you or like is it is it surreal like
that we went through the drive-through
and we've been trying to like the toys
come out like one at a time so we've
been trying to find sprites so my dad
every morning should be like i'm going
to mcdonald's and he goes to like four
different locations and he tries to find
it and we're with my friend and my mom
was like well let's just try it was like
10 30 at night and we drive through my
mom was like do you have the sprite toy
and the lady was like um i don't i don't
know eternal she's like i don't know
which one that is and my mom's like it's
it's the green one with the the red hair
and the girl was like oh yeah we have it
and i was like how many can i have and
she was like well how many do you want
and i was like can i have 20 and she's
like sure
and we drove through and they were so
like no one had any idea they were
really confused there's actually i
posted a video too i was like i'm in
that she's like
okay like it's it was so funny
but yeah my
my mom is collecting a set and i'm
collecting a set of like every eternal
finger it's all behind me and there's
like
calendars and
bracelets and
like so many things like
it just goes right over my head now it's
i don't even know how to comprehend at
all
no that that's awesome and that's like
living the dream fully and that's
awesome that you embrace it though and
that you enjoy it um that's so cool and
angela i think what a lot of people need
to know about you is that you have a
great
inspirational wisdom post you put on
twitter and instagram um i want to bring
up a quote you put on instagram i really
liked you said uh to hold a soft heart
in a hard world and to offer kindness
and love to yourself first and then the
world for if we can't be kind of
ourselves how can we be to others
i was wondering is this something you
apply every day and maybe elaborate a
little bit or more because i've been
reflecting on it actually since i read
it i think it's great oh thank you thank
you that's three that you looked into
that um
well i i think the pandemic this entire
year and a half almost two years that
we've been in
has been kind of a life-changing thing
and i had this experience at the
beginning of it well at the middle of it
where i was kind of getting rid of this
idea of who i thought i am
the ideas of
you know
being always kind of
this image that we hold ourselves to be
and i i i was going
who am i
who am i really on the day today who am
i to myself
and and then who am i to others because
if i can't be kind to myself if i can't
be
then i can't be kind to anybody else
that voice in our heads i think speaks
really really loudly and it doesn't say
kind things if it's judging ourselves if
it's
this is the reason i put the post it's a
great reminder a daily enlightenment to
be fun
to be kind because we're human sometimes
we make mistakes
yeah i feel like i want to pay you now
to give me like a therapy session that
was great
no i'm the first person that can give
you therapy i promise
love it everyone just got some free
wisdom um
my last question is for both of you uh
for people who are huge you know angela
sarafian and liam mchugh fans right
we're gonna go watch house on the bayou
what's your like if they're on the fence
what's the cell why should i go watch
this if i love watching you guys
when i read the script um i actually
this has happened a couple times before
but when i read the script
i read it all in like an hour very fast
and i looked up at my mom like halfway
through and i was like what the hell is
going on and and she was like what are
you reading i'm like i have no idea and
i like it it was i was so like confused
at a certain point and then i got all
the way through it and it was like the
circle moment and i'm like mom this is
really good and
it's it's very different than any other
horror movie it's not the cliche horror
movie and it it's not only you know
meaningless scares and jump scares it
actually has a lot of story line behind
it and you find i find that you care
about the characters a lot which i i
feel invests you more in the movie and
it makes those scares i guess more
you know effective
yeah
totally nailed angela what about you i
feel like she covered it like she's yeah
that answer am i right
yeah how do you follow it up i don't
know what to do
i like what what can i possibly add to
that if you want to have a good time and
you want to forget about your problems
come and watch the house on body
you won't think your life is so bad
anymore no you won't
that's it you heard it here see angela
and leah crush it in the house on the
bayou it's available this friday on
epics and for digital purpose via
paramount
home entertainment
angela thank you so much for joining me
and i hope to talk to you guys thank you
thank you thank you so much